good morning good afternoon or whatever
time it is welcome my name is Bob
greifeld I'm the CEO of nasdaq omx we
have some questions that we received
here today I'm happy to answer one or
two of them one Rako question was from
Brian support keeps you motivated well
to me there's two sources of motivation
one is desire to succeed and the other
is the fear of failure both of these
situations motivate me so depending upon
what the particular set of circumstances
are sometimes I really just have this
overwhelming desire to be successful
other times when we have probably a
platform in a given space I'm concerned
about failure and that's a motivation I
think they're both fine and proper
second question got from Sandra and what
are you doing specifically to invest in
innovation and job creation that's a
great question i think fundamental to
the success ready love economies all
around the world we have to innovate we
have to grow what we do at desert home x
is recognize that all great ideas cannot
comment for the top an organization or
even from me in the middle of the
organization so we have what we call
these councils which allows the person
in the organization come forward with a
concept and they'll be reviewed by their
peers we delegate your money to these
councils earlier in the year and they're
able to fund these worthwhile concepts
without having come to me or other
senior managers and we've seen that we
now have a plethora of really
interesting business opportunity some
small some mediums and large that we're
pursuing and each of these innovations
requires us to look to staff properly
and obviously that represents net job
creation from
from a psycho max and hope net economic
contribution to our shareholders and
obviously to help broad economic growth
so thank you I appreciate your time
today